hier ist wie du hast dich auch unter die
demonstranten gemischt peter zeichnete
uns gerade ein bild von durchaus vielen
gewaltbereiten demonstranten
ist das bei dir ebenso das kann ich
bestätigen
die demonstrationen hatten hoch
aggressiv angefangen bereits am anfang
haben mein kameramann und ich auch schon
einen schlag abbekommen wurden als nazis
beschimpft als lügen presse natürlich
auch hier fliegen flaschen steine wurden
auch schon geworfen ich heute beobachten
wie jugendliche im steine sich am boden
auch bis damit haben
ein auto ist er hat ja auch schon
gebrannt also die stimmung ist aggressiv
und ein bisschen außer atem
die stimmung ist hier ein anderes eve
und wir sind hier am ende der demo
vermitteln uns einmal einen eindruck wie
die polizei jetzt vorgeht bisher wir
haben es ja in den vergangenen wochen
bei demonstrationen gesehen hat die
polizei stets auf deeskalation gesetzt
also hat die demonstranten begleitet und
hat versucht so wenig wie möglich
einzugreifen jetzt wir sehen ja die
bilder dieser nacht ist die stimmung
jedoch eine ganz andere eine sehr
angespannte stimmung mit sehr vielen
gewaltbereiten demonstranten wir sehen
hier jetzt einmal live die bilder aus
der hauptstadt wir sehen dass es dort
die stimmung wirklich hochkocht autos
brennen flaschen fliegen polizeibeamte
werden angegriffen 1900 sind im einsatz
er ist mir noch mal die frage an dich
wie ist die strategie der polizei für
heute nacht ich glaube natürlich möchte
die polizei deeskalieren sie möchte
nicht dass es noch zu weiteren bränden
warten dürfen steinwürfen petra kommt
vandalismus ist hier glaube ich auch
eine spielt auch eine ganz große rolle
die polizei reagiert aber natürlich auch
diese angriffe der poli der
demonstranten
und das sieht man jetzt hier gerade
jetzt lasst uns einmal noch darauf
zurückkommen da ist
gangs erzählt dass du auch angegriffen
wurde hast du das gefühl dass sich diese
angriffe gezielt auch schon gegen
journalisten richten oder gehen die
demonstranten jetzt einfach in einer art
zerstörungs waren vor und greifen
polizisten oder alles was vielleicht von
halblinks offizieller seite her
berichtet oder dabei ist an dem uns die
wut der demonstranten richtet ich
gefühlt gegen alle also am anfang wurde
einmal aufgerufen
dass man doch die jugendpresse die naht
die youtuber und damit waren glaube ich
dir auch gemeint warum auch immer
doch nicht ihr film lassen sollte dass
man sich wehren sollte gegen sie und
sonst wird glaube ich hier komplett frei
geschossen ehrlich gesagt also die
polizisten bekommen hier viel ab
menschen werden angerempelt die sich
diese demo vielleicht nur anschauen
wollen
wir haben wie gesagt auch schon was
abbekommen uns wurde wie kamera oder mir
wurde die kamera so gegen halb
geschlagen das hat ihr glaube ich das
ist ja einfach nur noch pure wut und
verstörung gut wie hier herrscht die
demonstranten wollen ihr habe ich keine
politik hier keiner politischen
intentionen irgendwie männer hat man das
gefühl sondern es ist hier ein reines
machtspiel
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren